this is a production of Cornell
University
um I appreciate the introduction the
chance to be here and share some of
research that we've been doing for many
years and ongoing um I had tried to
suggest that gosh give this talk but
Janice really wanted me do it and so I'm
Redbook is represented in spirit hmm at
Wisconsin my doctorate and and also
master's at Virginia was very much
focused on agricultural production and
externalities and problems specifically
water quality and other ecological
implications of contemporary farming
practice and became very interested in
Agri environmental policy basically
federal elements of it thank you for
coming the farm bill and the
conservation elements of the farm bill
and have followed that closely for 25
years I want to talk about is a kind of
glass a half-full glass half-empty story
about the potential to bring more
science and more data and more modeling
to bear on how we do conservation and
opportunities to use a more data rich
approach to inform how we spend money in
Agri environmental programs more
generally how conservation is advanced
whether it's funded by private dollars
whether it's funded by public dollars
whether it's funded by voluntary
investments by farmers and ranchers
that's the half full side of the story
the half empty side is to look at the
history and the politics of Agriculture
particularly in this country but
certainly Europe wouldn't be very
different in which the commitments to
conservation are mixed on the one hand
there are strong commitments throughout
agriculture and among consumers in the
general public and bureaucrats and
elected officials to stewardship and
conservation and sustainability on the
other hand we have bedrock commitments
to cheap food both of these things are
true so we're kind of left with well
which which flavor is going to come out
in a given decision or in a given moment
so that's the kind of big picture that I
want to try to talk about today
so the talk and I will explain each of
these terms
somebody told me they'd shared the title
with a friend and they said I don't know
what any of these words mean so we'll go
through that um
conservation not just in North America
in the Midwest one slide there from
India um not just traditional
conservation practices like buffer
strips contour plowing conservation
tillage integrated pest management but
also next generation conservation I'm
part of the leadership group for this
Cornell Institute for digital
agriculture which is on the cusp of
being launched and so we're interested
in kind of futuristic visions of
agriculture food and conservation just a
kind of conservative hopefully a forward
the opportunity and I think the the kind
of upside the exciting elements respect
to ecology is to advance the
cost-effectiveness of conservation if
you only have one dollar if you only
have one conservation contract to give
what should you do with that dollar or
that conservation contract could we use
data to characterize distributions of
landscapes of farming systems to capture
that variance and use it in a way that
informs investment decisions and the way
we structure contracts with farmers to
do conservation under cost-sharing
arrangements you have variability in
farmers willingness to participate in
the amount of money they want to be paid
for that willingness to accept we have
variability in landscapes we have
variability in conservation practices
the width of the buffer strip the
architecture the way the buffer strip is
installed the way the buffer strip is
maintained all of these things are
parameters that matter in terms of the
cost effectiveness that is the cost of
creating maintaining a conservation
practice the opportunity cost perhaps in
terms of loss of arable land and crop
yield and the benefits in terms of local
and regional ecosystem services so
on-farm conservation benefits might be
soil erosion control off-farm
conservation benefits might be
addressing hypoxia and so the promise is
using data using knowledge about spatial
distributions and economic distributions
to spend and target conservation dollars
effectively we also can imagine
assessing conservation programs
rigorously in a data rich environment to
breed more cost-effectiveness and better
outcomes and so as I said it's a kind of
glass half full glass half empty on the
one hand were confronted with great
opportunities to bring data to bear the
types of science you folks are doing in
terms of models alysus 10 informant
should be informing conservation
practice my sense is it's not informing
it as deeply and as fast as it should
and the historical friction that
constrains we introduce new ideas new
practices and new data into conservation
planning and administration of
conservation programs that's the
historical fiction I want to talk about
so on the one hand there's new energy
there's new sense of Agriculture's
relationship with environment which is
driving demand for farming differently
for renegotiating the social contract
with farmers for putting a candle under
Congress so they invest differently
similarly for USDA and natural resource
conservation services all of that's fine
but on the other hand the world was not
created yesterday we're stuck with a
history we're stuck with organizational
culture we're stuck with a variety of
relationships that are represented in
what we call policy coalition's or
policy networks and the way that trade
groups and farm groups and environmental
groups and political interests are
articulated and come to agree on Agri
environmental policy in the past
conditions what opportunities
for renegotiating agri-environmental
policy in the present so history matters
I promised you definitions of each of
the terms in the title there you have it
so what does it mean to say I'm excited
about a data-driven or an outcome based
approach to Agri Environmental Policy it
immediately means that we don't live in
such a world today I think that Agri
Environmental Policy is relatively data
poor right now and it's not outcome
based so what's exciting is the idea
that people are going to bring models
about input and output relationships and
how variants in weather slope soil type
cropping system nutrient management
planning and practice map on to water
quality outcomes as an example
traditionally Agra environmental policy
has been premise on paying farmers for
practices install a buffer strip change
your rotation you split application of
nitrogen those are proxies for outcomes
of interest like improved water quality
enhanced biosecurity biodiversity
reductions in greenhouse gas emissions
but I think there's some problem and
dissatisfaction from relying on proxies
and I think that taxpayers and
administrators and elected officials
would be increasingly comfortable and
it's attractive to them to be able to
talk about an outcome based approach to
policy evidence-based policy where we
can actually say something and provide
some evidence about the relationship
between inputs which are dollars and
outcomes which are security well-being
as opposed to relying on how many people
came to your extension meeting how many
booklets did you distribute how many
farm meeting days did you host those are
all um outputs but they're not outcomes
and so moving to an outcome based
approach is a kind of new grammar of
policy and this is part of this idea of
data-driven excitement and bringing
science to bear Agri Environmental
Policy is the portfolio in this country
largely a federally funded conservation
practices I think we could also and I'll
talk
a bit of time allows about private
standards in the role of supermarkets
particularly in advancing and brushing
agri-environmental commitments on
landscapes critical analysis this is a
social scientific term to explicitly
signal that I want to question the
assumptions and the knowledge games that
are embedded in specific ways of framing
problems just because a problem is
expressed in a certain way in popular
imaginations or even in scientific
communities it doesn't mean that's the
only way we're best way to express them
so we always want to reflexively go back
and ask are we asking the right question
or whose question is being asked and
whose question is being ignored and
that's a critical analysis this issue of
institutional change institutions are
the kind of social infrastructure by
which behavior decisions relationships
development it's the structure by which
government markets and communities
function by being interested in
institutional change I'm interested in
the shifts in the social relationships
and commitments and ideas that structure
resource allocation and behavior in this
case I'm interested in institutional
change associated with
agri-environmental policy so can we do
it differently what mediates changes in
how we do the payments of farmers and
how we elicit conservation practices on
the landscape so a basic and I think
it's it's basically a theory of
everything interesting but it might not
hold water I agree with that
but I still want to share it with you as
a work-in-progress I'm particularly
interested in this piece in it the idea
is that we're constantly assessing
things asking questions about the world
we live in and we're taking actions and
those are kind of recursively related to
one another
we take action we reflect on it people
reflect on our actions it goes through
some cycle of evaluation there's a group
of actors organizations networks or
fields they're developing new
capabilities and new competencies to
take new actions those actions represent
new practices which reconstitute the
organizations and the population of
organizations in this case let's say
farms or fields that change in farming
practice and farms creates different
outputs economic social and ecological
and the cycle renews so we evaluate
things we make judgments about
accountability that puts pressure on
organization is like land-grant
universities and farms which create new
capabilities for a new round of action
which creates innovation or not which
reconfigures the field perhaps to create
a new round of outcomes which might be
improvement it might be degradation
it depends what lens and criteria the
dynamics associated with this theory of
everything on the one hand is
organizational ecology of you easy
changes in fields farms cropping systems
is there some selection pressure by
which we see change in the population of
actors and is there some kind of
accountability or legitimacy test that
creates actionable pressure and
selection which changes the character of
the field of Agriculture breeds new
competencies let's say to reduce nitrous
oxide emissions or reduce phosphorus
emissions or enhance biodiversity
through agricultural practice and how
does that change outcomes of interest
like greenhouse gas emissions so as a
theory of everything
let's not tackle it in this 45 minutes
together I'm really interested of do we
have an accountability crisis is that
driving something so every policy was
created in a particular context
the agricultural policy that I
recognized in the United States and also
in the UK Europe general came out of the
farm crisis of the mid-1980s chronic low
commodity prices and we had tremendous
shake out in the farm population family
farms are disappearing radically
Congress in this country stepped in in
many different ways one way they sin was
by providing payments to farmers for
conservation practices those dollars
were spent to protect soil protect water
projects but I think equally if not more
importantly those dollars were spent to
protect farmers and rural communities
but it's more under farmers incomes and
to reduce commodity and to boost
commodity prices by reducing supply so
by putting controls on land and taking
land out of production we were able to
reduce supply increased price and put a
floor under farmers incomes all of that
was bundled together under farm
legislation and bundled together under
agri-environmental payments so when I
say that every environmental payments
are not cost effective they weren't
designed to be those payments made to
farmers for multifunctional and so when
we say we're not getting as much
environmental benefit per dollar spent
the answer is yes it took me by surprise
there are 20 years to figure that out
but here I am we call them environmental
programs and they are environmental
programs but they're not and living with
that paradox it's not easy for me the
principles by which agri-environmental
payments are structured in this country
I'll stick with the u.s. there's a very
strong commitment to volunteers you see
that all the time with you
our algorithms are voluntary we have
cross compliance but by large they're
voluntary we rely on standards there's
not a tremendous amount of flexibility
and there's tremendous solidarity
solidarity among farmers and even more
so solidarity between USDA and farmers
there's a commitment not to put farmers
in a position of being subject to
discipline the USDA has long taken a
position that they're not willing to
police farmers they want to be a
resource in the agricultural community
and be an agent of change and be a
booster of Agriculture not and so this
idea that we're gonna flip into
something like payment for ecosystem
services and we're gonna use data and
we're going to use accountability and
we're going to rely on evidence based
outcome based approaches to deciding if
farmers will get paid and how much they
get paid my argument is that all of
those commitments don't fit easily with
historical commitments to relying on
standards not outcomes relying on
competition no let's rely on solidarity
and to rely really on financial
incentives strictly as opposed to
voluntary commitments and so this
historical basis for conservation
doesn't sit with this kind of future
vision of relying on the market-based
data-driven and that's the tension the
critique of agri-environmental paly as
agreeable policy has been poorly focused
that is not a new critique that's a
thirty-year-old critique at midnight
when the Conservation Reserve Program
was first created in 1985 the program
basically was organized on first-come
first-served
there was no scoring there was no EBI
environmental benefits index was
basically you walked in and said I want
at least the government my crop by crop
land for ten years they said yes they
didn't measure environmental benefits
they didn't really even look at rental
payments over time data administrative
techniques have been introduced to
ratchet up the amount of data and the
kind of rational rational logic but
there's more room for increased reliance
on data and a more rational competitive
approach to soliciting farmers involved
so I suggested that I'm interested in
this idea of accountability crisis or
legitimacy driving institutional change
in on offer I think three quotes that
highlight the fact that one this is not
a new debate and two it's an active
debate how many of you have heard of the
C program the conservation effects
assessment program I'm glad replic
you've heard of it it's in your
dissertation this is a 15 year old
program out of USDA and it's a massive
interagency program to evaluate the
state of the science underlying
conservation in animal and I think it's
a very ambitious program on the other
hand it's a strictly performative
program in that USDA is basically saying
don't look to us don't criticize us for
not having the scientific capability to
do conservation well and do it
efficiently we just spent 15 years doing
data synthesis and coming up with
standards and we've got it under control
and this concern about the effects and
the effectiveness of conservation arises
from critiques of USDA that come from
outside of the government in critiques
from inside the government the
government announcing office reports
that the USDA does not have adequate
processes in place
to optimize environmental performance
associated with and that they have very
weak administrative controls on how they
spend taxpayer money so it's been an
ongoing if effort to highlight and put
pressure on Congress and on USDA and
Natural Resource Conservation Service to
up their game and to bring new tools and
new rationality this month there's a new
piece of legislation introduced to
Congress called the agricultural data
Act and in the context of the Cornell
digital agriculture initiative some
significance but it creates a
possibility and laying great researchers
are the specific beneficiaries in the
legislation to get access to field and
farm level records of conservation and
agronomic practice and this would be
revolutionary any of you have tried to
get access to farm management data it's
not easy
whether you go through Hoya or you end
up doing individual surveys whether we
view this as an opening of the door to
have more data and more access to data I
think you could read it the other way if
you read this quite carefully what's
actually being talked about is the
competitiveness and the economic
performance of farm they do mention soil
health but you don't see here a
commitment to opening up for example all
of the data that we relevant to analyze
water quality bustard my point is simply
to emphasize that this conversation
about data creating data capturing data
creating access to data using data is an
active conversation so the critique of
USDA the critique of agriculture broadly
defined in terms of environmental
performance is an old story I think
there's lots of reasons to think that
agriculture is coming under increasing
scrutiny and that there's increasing
pressure on Congress on USDA and on
farmers
invest differently in conservation
persistent environmental problems
whether it's greenhouse gas emissions
and nitrous oxide whether it's golf
wetland loss soil erosion they all
continue to be significant animals we
can argue about how effectively they've
been abated but they certainly have new
modeling capability we have new sensing
capability we have no capacity to huge
warehouse synthesize data computer
science I think there's a general
appetite for moving to outcome based and
evidence-based policy and I think
there's a general appetite for exposing
actors inside of bureaucracy and in this
case farmers to new discipline the tools
in the of what's called new Public
Management or neoliberalism all of those
ideas using object using a kind of value
for money test all seems to have kind of
currency in a contemporary environment
and I think the time is ripe to bring
more data and more accountability to
bear on farmers with respect to Agri
environmental policy and also similarly
not just farmers but also the way USDA
spends that money so my argument is and
I think there is pressure on this
remember I showed you that theory of
everything and the arrow to the top
right showed this legitimacy and
accountability push that puts pressure
to start the cycle towards new
competencies and changes in practices
and innovation that leads to different
socio ecological outcomes but I put this
with a question mark because a Greco
chur Agri environmental policy has been
in crisis for 30 years there's not a new
crisis the opportunity I said the
glasses have the opportunity here is to
model on a site-specific basis inputs
and outputs to understand the
relationship between farming practices
local environmental conditions and
conservation
interventions and how those yield
benefits and of course healed costs and
by using data and striving to pay for
results to maximize conservation
benefits under budget constraint we
could make taxpayer dollars go further
we could enhance the environment and in
theory not create dips in farm income or
spikes in fringe cost of food whether we
can achieve that win-win it's important
nonetheless we could make an analysis
that would allow us to intervene in
conservation in a way that's more
surgical and precise that's the
opportunity the constraints the reason
that we haven't picked up these $10
bills off the floor the reasons that we
already haven't harnessed the power of
data and models to drive conservation
and achieve something like precision
conservation I want to argue we can make
sense of through three bullet points
specification problems estimation
problems and the historical problem of
political economic relations when we
think about the specification problems
it becomes clear that agriculture is a
big industry very heterogeneous
conditions and lots of different kinds
of problem so if we said we're going to
increase the cost-effectiveness of
conservation you would say well what do
you mean oh you mean surface water or
groundwater you mean wetlands or do you
mean
greenhouse gases do you mean soil
erosion or do you mean farmworkers
health there's lots of different things
that can be optimized and lots of
different things that we could invest in
and so this problem of specification is
quite messy how do you make commensurate
and comparable these different types of
social priorities and aspirations and
the answer is you don't really do it
economists might say that they have
techniques or philosophers I say they
have techniques but it's pretty messy
business when you try to get people to
agree on what are the benefits change
you're most interested
and how would you value those lemons
would a conservation benefit in suburban
New York 40 miles from New York City the
value of that conservation because of
the density of the population would make
conservation in South Dakota impossible
if you did it on a dollar basis
there's the willingness to pay of those
consumers and the number of consumers is
so high you tried to rationalize that
spending on some economic calculation
you'd be stuck with a very messy problem
all of the spending would be in urban
metropolitan areas and deep rural areas
would get nothing and so this idea of
using data using economics to specify
where to invest in how to invest is not
straightforward and it opens up lots of
ethical philosophical legal and
political questions estimation
estimating costs and benefits of
conservation is non-trivial I assume
many of you are doing this for a living
at it it's non-trivial the models the
scale of those models the data
requirements of those models make it
tough the costs of those models are the
transaction costs of moving to a data
rich environment are non-trivial the
more data we have to collect the more
data we have to make sense of all of
that costs and what are the benefits
well it depends and we can argue not
only do you have to estimate the
benefits of a conservation practice but
in order to do that you have to have a
baseline for a counterfactual scenario
against which to compare it so in theory
you'd have to collect data before you
make a conservation intervention then
you have to collect data after you make
the conservation intervention then you
have to parameterize the weather then
particularly happen during that growing
season or that week and make sense of
that all of that is costly and difficult
and we're not there yet so the
challenges of estimating economic and
ecological performance of conservation
in site-specific environments are
non-trivial
and this very much impedes this kind of
move
this flip of institutional change into a
data rich outcome-based
and the last one of political economy
all of you think in high school at least
if you're when us high schools or
familiar with the Iron Triangle where
interest groups develop relationships
with bureaucrats which lead to a
regulatory failure institutional failure
we basically have a situation in which
Congress is not interested in imposing
greater discipline on us ta they're not
interested in imposing greater
discipline on farmers and I think we
could say the same thing for USDA they
do not want to be the policemen of
Agriculture and it's not going to help
them with their mission not politically
their organizational culture is kind of
boots on the ground they don't
necessarily want to be in the basement
with models crunching numbers
it'd rather be having conversations with
farmers and trying to build
relationships that yield positive
outcomes for agriculture and so I think
the most important thing is that there
is a great ambivalence about imposing
discipline on farmers that's not how we
come to this point and now if you
imagine we're going to use data use
economics use models use satellites use
drones to figure out how conservation
should be organized they're going to
impose that knowledge on the landscape
through farmers it's a tough sell so the
opportunity is to use science new
politics and new thinking to make more
cost-effective approaches to
conservation it constraints our
specification estimation and now it
doesn't mean that we're stuck although I
think maybe it doesn't mean we're stuck
but I think that there are possibilities
I'm going to close in a minute I want to
hear
you where you think this could go I
think the smart money's on more of the
same that's where the smart money is
we're locked into this relationship and
I think it's important to recognize you
know that the u.s. farm bill we bundle
together
agricultural policy and food assistance
over 80% of spending in the farm bill is
food assistance and this means that
urban states are invested in the farm
bill not just rural states and this is a
kind of mutual non-aggression treaty
between Iowa and New York Iowa and
Massachusetts that we're not going to
spit on your shoes and you're not going
to spit on my shoes and this is a very
clever way to do agricultural policy in
a big and diverse country when it comes
to saying let's ratchet up the data on
farmers and let's get some conservation
people are particularly interested I
think more of the same is in the cards I
think you know the cost of sensors is
dropping radically it's amazing what's
happening with sensors the potential to
use secondary data and aerial
photographs and satellites and drones so
these other ways to do sensing both in
field in plant tissue but also remotely
creates all types of new opportunities
it can drive down the costs of data
collection revolutions in artificial
intelligence data synthesis in
architecture of computing creates all
types of opportunities to do useful
things with that data maybe we're going
to have a data revolution don't hold
your breath
private standards just because Congress
won't act doesn't mean Walmart won't act
the private standards over the last 20
years to become very very important in
agriculture and not just in the United
States but around the world large
powerful retailers are promoting in some
case dictating concert farming practices
pesticide use selection of varieties
irrigation scheduling in a variety of
ways
it's possible that value chains and
relationships farmers have with retail
or food processors could lead to a more
data rich a more rational and a more
accountable and a more kind of
disciplinary environment in which
conservation is practiced it's possible
and I think this idea of payment for
ecosystem services how many here heard
of p/es payment this idea of using this
logic would fit quite neatly under a
private scheme of organizing production
with farmers and incentivizing them to
engage in conservation I think that the
political coalition's that gave rise in
the 1980s could be reconfigured and
recreated it happened once it could
happen again I think we should not be so
myopic to think that we only lived
through the only history histories being
created every day and there could be new
history I have been waiting for 30 years
I'm still waiting it's possible that you
know we're gonna reach some type of
nitrogen cascade Greenland ice shelf
melting that will flip us into a new
reality with the new politics that's not
a particularly rosy future but it is
possible if we want to see how could a
gree environmental change agreement it
has a more I've written that it might
interest in the idea that farmers come
clean and say yes it's a dirty industry
but we are gonna take ownership of that
and we want regulatory forgiveness and
we want money and we want the support of
the land-grant universities to farm
differently so instead of denying the
problems of environment own them which
would be a complete flip from from our
Bureau Federation and commodity groups
currently function there's variety out
there but by and large I don't think
agriculture production agriculture has
been particularly engaged and
progressive when it comes to ecology
they mostly have been denying and
shunting off blamed urban populations
so all of these are possibilities that
could shake up this kind of stickiness
that we confront ourself that we find
ourselves on the one hand new
capabilities and data being created and
they're finding their way in unevenly
into policy on the other hand there's
lots of reasons we don't see a data
revolution so coming to a close as we
reflect on institutional change
everything is it possible that crisis of
legitimacy and accountability can create
a dynamic of progress of learning of
enriching administration and practice
through bringing data to bear I don't
know despite the fact that the number of
farms the percentage of the population
engaged culture drops the economics
increasingly in urban society for all
these reasons people have said that
Agriculture's political power will wane
it hasn't happened yet agriculture still
remains a very potent political block
for historical cognitive and cultural
reasons I think it's interesting to
think about can the Government
Accounting Office put a candle under
Congress and under USDA can the state
fix itself or is it civil society social
movements and science that could somehow
catalyze a change and we look at
critiques of knowledge systems science
data are implicated in Agriculture USDA
like all bureaucracies and agriculture
like all sectors are very adept at
collecting criticism and deflecting
criticism the USDA took this critique of
the knowledge base underlying
conservation and turned it into a
victory party a celebration of how much
they knew and how forward-looking they
are that's a glass-half-full perspective
in some ways these sectors are so
politically entrenched that they are
somehow bulletproof but of course
they're not change does happen but it's
slow with that I close
[Applause]
legitimacy in credibility synonymous
legitimacy and credibility I think yes
and no I think legitimacy generally we
talk about legitimacy as conformance
with sets of norms and practices that
are commensurate or compatible with
cognitive and legal standards and so
it's a kind of conformance problem so is
the practice is the behavior map on to
some standard credibility I guess is
more about accuracy or validity which
might be subject to a more technical
assessment so legitimacy is not really
subject to a technical assessment does
it kind of feel right does it resonate
with you as being kosher
that would be a kind of qualitative
assessment of credibility I don't know I
guess I'm thinking a more technocratic
approach to evaluating credibility how
do you think about them
well the legitimacy you know you know
fitting into existing structures I
haven't really thought well that does
sound right credibility is just can you
you know you know do you believe the
results of the study yeah I think my
point is that if the credibility of USTA
the credibility of conservation practice
the credibility of conservation science
if all of that stuff is brought into
question and it will have lost its
legitimacy legitimacy will be tarnished
which creates an opening for something
new not necessarily something better but
something different so credibility why I
think would be an important element of
legitimacy
I was wondering or watching history we
have a unique opportunity now to make
history here at an academic institution
yeah I'm aware about the the credibility
lost or the interview by a large
proportion of this country society
towards academia but but still we which
stood a little bit outside of a lot of
the structure we can play and we can
demonstrate them you mentioned
data-driven evidence and and the the
revolution in in sensing technology
these days if we could just show what
what there is what is possible I would
think that there ought to catch on to
turn the time
I'm also a little bit worried about the
double standards that there are some
environmental externalities that I'm a
little bit more familiar with such as
carbon trading or payments for carbon
sequestration Breanna solution
reductions where whether there is
already the absolute need for data you
have to really show that you can you
sequester carbon or reduce emissions and
in the landscape that is also a metered
through remote sensing or in field
measurements sometimes who practices but
more often through evidence of actual
reductions or sequestration so why not
disagreement why do they think they can
live outside our society in just saying
okay I do it give me 200 bucks per per
acre and never check it never check that
actually a cheese pudding supposed to
achieve that doesn't work in any other
sector yeah so good thank you
the first one I think the idea that
scientists in the scientific community
can create new tools and provide
evidence which then is taken up through
some magical process by legislators and
by practitioners as some validity it's
it's there's some reason to believe that
there's a kind of linear process by
which good ideas and proven technologies
find their way even if there is a
political fence or there's ignorance or
there's bias so history shows that good
ideas can find their way but in general
I think we see lots of situations where
political and economic constraints
require that we don't rely on this kind
of passive approach and that we have to
be in the fray and so Cornell's engaged
initiative is very much about saying we
need to do research in a way that is in
relation with communities and
practitioners in the general public and
not rely on this passive approach to
will do the science will burp up good
ideas and they'll find their way out
there into
practice to be more strategic and I
mention companies that's what I I agree
and we do enjoy great privilege to be
isolated from a lot of pressures and
monitoring you know this whole analysis
could be used for citation evaluations
for your productivity and your impact
assessment reports right that we're all
on the verge of being subject to
discipline and data so don't wish it on
the farmers if you don't wish it on
yourself the second point that I think
that well the the third point is I think
it is remarkable that farmers enjoy such
a regulatory vacuum and forgiveness
largely unregulated we could say Capo's
are regulated the Clean Water Act
pesticide labeling yeah yeah yeah
agriculture has got it good and they
know it yes so Rick and I have a paper
the revisions were due yesterday I have
to get busy
I want to share this with you because
our paper shows that the science and the
rigor associated with creating measures
of additionality real value created so
some difference according to a baseline
are constructed in a way that resembles
sausage-making you know that joke about
policymaking and so I would say all of
these approaches to measurement involve
on the one hand rigor and empiricism and
the other hand swamp and I wouldn't want
to characterize some of them as the gold
standard and bulletproof and that
science and this is just folk wisdom and
they're making it up I think we can find
validity and credibility in folk
practice and and grounded practice and
we can find nonsense in what is called
science I'll send you this paper and
it's on nitrous nitrous oxide and
cars nitrous-oxide protocol for doing
offset payments in corn production based
on the kellogg biological field stations
data other questions comments thanks
so here constraints to do big progress I
broke them down into two categories
first was to state problem is hard and
the second is to say we don't have the
will to address the problem and if you
agree with that categorization but he
needed that second word is
hierarchically more important than the
first part in other words if we had the
will to address the problem and maybe
Cornell does have a well with the
initiative for data and agriculture to
address the problems but you know us ei
to government in general maybe not
terribly international allergies or into
rewarding friends and I a logical allies
so what are you doing
yes you're asking the right questions
and I do think that if we had political
commitments that the technical problems
but they wouldn't take care of
themselves but those are are we doing
the right things versus doing things
right so first are we doing the right
things and that's a political and a
cultural problem I think that and I have
deeply ambivalent about this whole
future putting the the screws to farmers
equipping the Natural Resource
Conservation Service with comprehensive
data from remote sensing platforms and
integrative tools to know what everyone
had for breakfast and so forth that's
not a particularly rosy future so we can
find ourselves in a very dark place with
these kind of data rich futures you've
all seen black mirror so I think that we
don't want to go overboard and we need
to keep in mind that if we're all
excited or not if I'm excited about
bringing data to bear to create value
for taxpayers and introduce discipline
to the way we pay farmers to do
conservation yes but I think we have to
have some caution
some respect and some modesty about
where this could take us so I agree we
have a political problem but the
solution I think is not to go around and
say you guys are our troglodytes and
you're not using data and data rules and
we're all gonna be technic rats right I
think that's a kind of we were I assume
you wouldn't want to go there either
right so I think it's kind of a delicate
a delicate issue I what else is but I
would say the first one specification is
not a hard problem it's a wicked problem
this question of do we value wetlands
more than greenhouse gas is more than
groundwater more than phosphorus for the
nitrogen and how would we sort that out
except through a political process I
don't think it's a technical it's not a
hard problem it's a values problem so it
is hard but it's not technical I was
thinking you might benefit by looking at
other countries I've lived the
Netherlands most of the time and that's
got much longer history of using science
directly in policy and has led to
regulation and a confrontational
approach where the farmers typically say
there are many examples they use nitrate
models specifically regulate amounts of
newer there's phosphate regulations
recently very strongly strengthened and
water quality it's very different
society but I was just thinking unique
compare different countries and then how
the Institute because you're interested
in how the institutions the different
ministries for example in that case have
changed that would be an interesting
comparison thank you I'm very much
interested in comparative across sectors
and across countries in how institutions
are configured and how they change I do
think that is not totally absolved of
these problems I think that there's
still a lot of corporatism consensus
base not just science-based yes very
much agreement but I would say the
politics are the happiest country in the
world
yeah right so and they also have a
really clean politics and they have a
really rich
and educated citizenry and they in there
forest management same problems we have
by and large very high trust in public
institutions very well-educated people
plenty of money for the state and they
still suffer from some of these same
things I talked about so it's always
better in Europe this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu